what-what-what-what check yo'self before  I body pierce your damn skull think you  could pull that trigger or I'll blow  your personality out the back of your  head  don't go run ahead and test the  hypothesis and see what happens hi I'm  gonna give you a straight-up vampire  c-section like we was Edward and Bella  Oh God  you like Twilight yeah I'd like try like  you like Twilight Twilight's my jam you  Edward God take him answer that together  three two one Edward are you with me I  just read the plans to dubgame well you  were straight up inside my head yo and  when you said you was gonna blow my  personality out the back of my head I'm  like that's what I was saying and now  there's twilight's wavelength so I guess  we fries that I win best friends now  we're best friends  BFFs we are BFFs mmm  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Laughter]  looks like another gang-related killer  surprise mother prize  [Laughter]  [Music]